ask for help whenever you don't know
where you're going ask for help that's
the face of a happy child right
good morning good morning good morning
this is our day for in Disney
magical day it is a magical day very the
sun is shining on my face because it
knows that you're an angel
okay
I was gonna say something but maybe I
should have said anything oh all right
let's go wow we're gonna have some
Hollywood studios here we come
all right we arrived gonna walk into the
entrance and wait a little bit they open
at 8 30. we are like half an hour early
but sometimes they let us in earlier so
yeah let's go
we got in they let us in sharp 8 30 not
30 early or after
okay Hayden is not feeling well so he
just went home with Nina so I'm here
with Captain and Jeffrey and change of
plans
we're gonna make it count
let's go
okay we're getting started in Star Wars
land first ride Smuggler's run I gotta
navigate I gotta
I actually don't know where I'm going
I'm gonna stop filming to figure out
where I'm going
foreign
ask for help
ask for help stop trying to do
everything yourself let's go
[Music]
all right we have arrived at our first
stop Smugglers Run we're gonna go fly
the Millennium Falcon
let's go
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
all right what did we think Catherine
good but you were burning your puppet we
are the greatest engineering team of all
time what do you think no no well yeah
yeah and also I'm a great Commander
you're a great Commander all right let's
go
next stop Muppet Vision 3D
it's pink let's go
[Music]
what did you think Catherine what good
what was the best part
what was the best part yeah when the
tiny thing turned into a Mickey Mouse
when you turn into Mickey Mouse all
right very cool
foreign
where are we going you want to go to
Star Tours
Star Tours
okay
Star Tours
[Music]
we can't record it in there you can't
record in there
or smoking well I hope not
[Music]
Jeffrey was totally scared
he was scared at the end the ending no
spoilers but he was scared how'd you
like it Captain Gary I loved it you
loved it all right
let's go
[Music]
next stop is going to be the Indiana
Jones epic stunt spectacular
before uh we go in oh let's go here
we're gonna get some refreshments make
sure we have uh some hydration and some
snacks ready to go so we're going to get
some Starbucks
here we go
[Music]
Indiana Jones
epic stunt spectacular
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
okay next stop is what we booked the
genie plus service with the slinky
[Music]
slunky
lintonimus something
but we're early so we're gonna we're
gonna chill for a little bit
see what we see along the way let's go
Walt Disney
one man's dream
this is actually my favorite thing the
history the Visionary Walt Disney kids
don't like it but I love this stuff
makes me want to think bigger
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
ER slink slink coaster
extravaganza
second most popular thing to do in this
park
so we were debating whether I should
film while on the ride or not
the kids are worried that I'm going to
drop the phone
and I'm kind of worried that I'm going
to drop the phone so I'll film some
b-roll and then we'll go on the ride
I'll scream for my life
keep my phone
and then we'll continue on
[Music]
not free it's really good really good he
liked it some minor drops
final drops
all right let's go get some lunch
ronto Roasters with maybe a Coke grenade
Maybe
we'll see I'm excited ronto Roasters is
uh one of the must must eat places
apparently in Star Wars lines so let's
see what they got for us
[Music]
so they have pop grenades Coke grenade
Spike grenade we gotta try it
let's go in here and open it up and have
a drink
Jeffrey already had his Coke grenade he
likes it she likes it hat back
all right grenades thoroughly enjoyed
very refreshing we're gonna we're gonna
take these home I like this
I like I like it special brand name here
a little difficult to hold because
there's no handle or anything but it's
all good
and if you actually shook this up and
and threw it at somebody and they opened
it it would explode so that's cool that
was Jeffrey's idea
okay we're gonna go to uh a new ride I
haven't been on it before Mickey and
Minnie's Railway ride of something new
ride let's go
[Music]
all right we're here
Mickey Mouse
in perfect picnic
Mickey and Minnie's runaway Railway
let's go
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
we didn't get all of it on on camera
because when it goes dark I can't record
properly when we got on there's this
little safety bar that you pull in and
Catherine decided to pull it right into
my stomach
on my door
right into the stomach says
right after that huge meal I got a bar
in my son for the whole time but we made
it happen it's the best and now we have
a little bit of time
before we had to Oh The Toy Story shoot
off so a couple days ago uh we did a
shooter game at Universal
Universal
and uh I I kind of destroyed this guy no
listen I won he's lying no no that's
actually not true I what he's saying
essentially what I'm saying is true I
had 73 000 points and he had 50
something it was that was a solid number
two but this is our rematch so it's a
shooter game
in Toy Story we gotta we gotta sit in
the cart and shoot a whole bunch of
aliens so this is round two
we'll see who the
who the better shooter is I'm looking to
defend my title Jeffrey's trying to make
the The Comeback and avoid
complete humiliation
let's go have some fun Catherine is
insisting to put sunscreen on me all
right
it's fine everything's fine it hurts
what do you mean it hurts it stings
I need to hold somebody's hand through
this here I might faint
holding my hand
I'm scared
you're fine nervous you're fine I need a
popcorn treat after this yeah sure
wait who's buying it
oh you oh perfect okay
and then we'll eat half of it whoa
the popcorn talks
that's an expensive tax 50 percent
that's why you're an entrepreneur so you
don't pay as many taxes
got to weave those life lessons into the
videos guys food for life lessons and
content
[Music]
okay no more filming Gotta Get My Game
Face on gotta win
let's go should we show these show these
kids what's up sorry what all right
we're checking in on the scores I got I
got one she got 76. not bad we went game
cap we gotta reverse it I got 125 76 for
Catherine 125 for me Jeffrey Jeffrey
see we'll see how we did when we got a
125 for me I completely messed up the
first round and my arm is dying yeah you
got to pull these strings back and forth
my arm is it hasn't been exploded you
did well
she was ahead of me in the first round I
I kind of didn't know what I was doing
yeah she did it she crushed it
you're a machine even holding the phone
up right now is is hard it'll work
happening it works now the the true test
how did Jeffrey do all right G what'd
you
get
[Music]
oh
we lost
we lost this guy all right well that
makes us now we're officially even we're
officially even good job good job G good
job
we're gonna have to show them we have
one more shooting game on the last day
of Disney I think tomorrow I think we
have one more this is it that's for all
the marbles let's see who the ultimate
shooter is
all right we are closing down on our
time here at Hollywood Studios we are
going to
go get some blue milk from Blue cows
from Luke well blue milk one of the one
of the treats you get here in Star Wars
land so we're gonna get some blue milk
hopefully tastes amazing then from Blue
cows then the biggest attraction in all
of Disney right now Star Wars something
resistance you have to pay you have to
you have to wake up early and then pay
15 bucks to get on this ride or you wait
two hours in line to get on so I woke up
early I paid we're going did everything
everything the last step is we're going
to go to uh when we travel and we do on
vacations and stuff so the kids don't
ask us for everything under the sun we
say one toy one surprise one treat one
thing that is your souvenir for each
trip so Catherine bought this backpack
Hayden is uh feeling better so it's
Grady's at home resting with Nina he got
a magic wand from from Harry Potter
and Jeffrey hasn't gotten anything
but he loves Nike so we go to a Nike
outlet store on the way home and see if
we can find him yeah but next stop
blue milk let's go
[Music]
there it is the blue milk and they got
green oh with straws perfect these three
things were like 20
seven bucks something like that so I
hope it's good let's see what do they
think and did you take a sip oh no did
you take a sip Captain took a sip how
was it
one second
and good okay let's go let's go get some
shade and start trying this blue milk
here we go no shade
what do you think G
good no good
oh First Step that first step deal right
there
okay
so the blue is blueberry or Berry and
the green that they got is citrus
here we go this is the official taste
test
no it's pretty good but yeah good car
guys
[Music]
the greatest ride in all of Walt Disney
World apparently
Star Wars rise of the resistance
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
what happened we weren't allowed to film
they don't let you film The Back process
ride is closed
they gave us
a free pass back in when and if it opens
but it expires today and now we gotta go
so didn't quite get the full experience
gives us a reason to come back but it
was a heck of a ride
it was a it was a pretty good ride
before we got there that's the face of a
happy child right
I completely agree
Jeffrey agrees happy child all right
well we're gonna head out
and we enjoyed the time we had gonna get
to the car at least it's not raining
it's supposed to thunder shower on us
today head uh to the car get to the Nike
outlet for Jeffrey and then go home and
maybe in the pool we'll see
[Music]
look at these clouds behind me that is
some rain about to come
let's get to the car before it showers
down
[Music]
thank you
all right so I didn't I didn't end the
video yesterday because Evan did all the
filming because I was home with Hayden
he wasn't fitting too well he's feeling
better now yeah he's feeling better now
yeah anyway so
um yesterday what did they do what did
we do when we get home they chill
Catherine went for a swim and then uh uh
we had dinner and then we watched the
shows like every night we watch a show
and then we went to sleep all right if
you want to see what we did on the last
day at Magic Kingdom Magic Kingdom Here
we go check out the video next to me I
think you can enjoy continue to believe
[Music]